The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: What
we're going to be
doing over the next few
days, today and on Tuesday,
is really diving into
the device fundamentals,
and then on Tuesday,
the materials
fundamentals, of how a solar
cell device really works.
And what we've done so
far is skimmed along
at a very high level using
only the necessary physics
and nothing more to describe
how solar cell works.
Because we want to give you
an intuition about solar cell
device operation.
PROFESSOR: The alternative
way of teaching
PV is that we go heavy on
the device physics upfront,
you're completely overloaded,
your RAM is completely full,
and by the time we
actually get to IV curves,
you're completely lost.
So hopefully you have
some intuitive sense now
about how a PV device works.
Now we're going to be
doing some deep dives
into some advanced
concepts so that we really
have a sophisticated
understanding of how
a solar cell works.
So let's dive into the lecture
material for the 1D device
model, we want to be able
to create a one dimensional
model that describes how
a solar cell operates.
So we want to capture all
of the necessary physics
from the materials
and the device
to describe the
IV characteristics
of a solar cell.
So we'll do at
the very beginning
is start a little
bit of nomenclature
so we understand what we're
talking about in terms
of energy conversion efficiency
and quantum efficiency.
And then we'll start describing
the different parameters
that effect energy conversion
efficiency and efficiency here.
So one of the first key concepts
that's very, very important
to understand is that energy
conversion efficiency is not
the same thing as
quantum efficiency.
You'll here these two
terms used quite frequently
the PV community.
Now, I would say we're really
starting to get sophisticated
about their use.
In the very beginning of
the field-- well let's
put it this way, in the
third wave of PV, which
began at around late 1990s
early 2000s, which was really
when, say, some of
the novel materials--
quantum dot-based solar cells,
some modern organic material
based solar cells-- really
started to take off,
there wasn't that sophisticated
of understanding of some
of the nomenclature in PV.
And so terms were used
in a confusing way.
When you read some of the papers
back from the early 2000s,
you might pick up
on some of this.
And So that's why I have this
slide right here describing
very clearly what is
quantum efficiency
and what is energy
conversion efficiency.
So energy conversion efficiency
is pretty easy to understand.
We've been talking
about that all class.
about how photon
comes in with a certain
amount of energy.
And you extract electrons
for your solar cell device
that of a certain
amount of energy.
And that ratio would be the
energy conversion efficiencies,
essentially the
energy coming out
divided by the energy going in.
So if, for example, one
photon comes in with three EV
and generates an electron
hole pair, which is then
extracted from the device with
a voltage of say 0.6 volts,
we would have an
energy conversion
efficiency less than 1,
somewhere around 15% or so.
Whereas if we looked
at quantum efficiency
and define quantum efficiency
as the number of electrons
out per incident
photon, that means
if we have one photon coming
in and one electron coming out
of our device, we have a quantum
efficiency of 1, or 100%.
So quantum efficiency
can be thought
of as collection efficiency.
It means how many electron hole
pairs were generated inside
of the device, and how
many were collected
coming out of the device.
There's a little bit
more to it than that
dealing with reflectivity
off the surface.
I'll get to that slide or two.
But it can be thought of roughly
as collection efficiency,
as whereas energy conversion
efficiency is really
what you think of in terms
of thermodynamic efficiency
of a device.
Why is this important?
Well, there are
papers out there--
this is an old one, I think,
in nature of materials,
if I'm not mistaken,
that started
using a bunch of terms, right.
So under 5 volts
bias and illumination
from a 975 nanometer
laser-- so nothing
like a polychromatic
solar spectrum,
this is a monochromatic
light source--
our detectors show an internal
quantum efficiency of 3%.
The photovoltaic response
under this monochromatic light
results in a maximum open
circuit voltage of so and so,
a short circuit current 350
nanoamps-- very, very tiny--
and a short circuit current
internal quantum efficiency
of 0.006%.
So what they're
talking about here
is a quantum
efficiency of 0.006%.
As we've already done just
by the simple example the 3 V
phonon coming in and
exciting electron hole
pair, quantum efficiency
of 1 but energy conversion
efficiency below
20%, we can already
guess that the energy
conversion efficiency
of a device like this, even
for monochromatic light,
is going to be very low.
So the reason I'm highlighting
this abstract right here
is because it's a great
example of the plethora
of different terms that you
can find in reading a paper.
And if you focus on just a few
of them, like oh, 3%-- wow,
that's awesome, 3%
device efficiency.
No, it's not energy
conversion efficiency.
That's the quantum efficiency
under a very specific bias
condition, reverse bias is
like a photo detector, not
a solar cell, not under
forward bias conditions.
OK, so what does
this really mean,
this 0.006% short circuit
internal quantum efficiency?
Well, we defined our energy
conversion efficiency
or solar conversion efficiency
as power out divided by power
in.
That was done in the
previous lectures.
The power out to would
the power and the current
and the voltage product at the
maximum power point divided
by the solar flux coming in.
And that would be
equivalent to the fill
factor times the short circuit
current times the open circuit
voltage.
And typical values for
energy conversion efficiency
are in the 12% to 20%
range, I would say.
Maybe less than 10% for
emerging technologies.
But these are typical values.
And the solar flux, the
illumination intensity
might vary as well.
But typically we talk about
one sun, or AM 1.5 illumination
conditions, right.
So that's our spectrum
at AM 1.5 conditions,
what we did on
homework number one.
Now the quantum efficiency
has two flavors.
One we'll call external
quantum efficiency
and the other internal
quantum efficiency.
And basically the
difference between them
is the reflectance off the
front surface of the device.
The internal quantum
efficiency essentially
factors out the reflectance.
The external quantum efficiency
is really taking reflectance
into account as well.
So external quantum
efficiency is
defined as electrons out per
photons toward the device.
We say photons in,
but this is really
how many photons are impingent
upon the device itself.
Some of those photons
will be reflected off
the front surface.
Other photons will
go into the device
and generate
electron hole pairs.
Or some will go straight
through the device
and be absorbed in the
back surface or so forth.
So the EQE, external quantum
efficiency, typical peak
values range between
60% and 90% depending
on the reflectivity for
moderate efficiency devices.
So the reason peak
values ranging 60 to 90
is because there's going to
be some band of wavelengths
at which the solar cell
really responds well.
It's really efficient at
converting those photons
into electron hole pairs.
And were the sun-- instead
of a beautiful polychromatic
blackbody emission
source-- if the sun where
a monochromatic
light source tuned
to that particular
wavelength, the solar cell
would be wicked efficient.
But it's not.
So this is why EQE is
an interesting parameter
is because it tells
you the response
of the solar cell to
different spectral conditions.
And that's why we sometimes
call it spectral response
of a solar cell device.
By the way, those
who need notes,
if you would be so kind
as to raise your hand,
Joe will pass them around as
well so we can have enough
for everybody to write down.
Any questions thus far on EQE,
external quantum efficiency,
the difference between QE and
the difference between ECE,
or shall we say, the energy
conversion efficiency?
Okay.
AUDIENCE: Quantum
efficiencies, they also
include [INAUDIBLE]
photons, right?
Or do they just
include photons which
have a potential to make
an electron [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: In principle,
QE, or sorry, EQE,
should have EQE as a
function of lambda, really.
And the photon in
is going to be,
obviously, at a certain
wavelength usually.
I've rarely heard EQE given
in a polychromatic sense where
they take an entire
solar spectrum
and measure the quantum
efficiency average.
Usually quantum efficiency
is measured wavelength
by wavelength.
And so you might change
your monochrometer settings
20 or 30 times
over, or even more,
over a quantum efficiency
measurement to really
map out the entire
solar spectrum
from short wavelengths
in the ultraviolet
all the way to longer
wavelength and the infrared.
And you're absolutely right.
Some of those wavelengths,
the photo response
of the solar cell will
be very close to 0
because it just doesn't respond
well at that wavelength.
Maybe the wavelength
is too short
and is being absorbed
by some surface layer.
Or maybe the wavelength is too
long it's just going straight
through [INAUDIBLE] photon.
Whereas energy conversion
efficiency is really
taking the entire solar
spectrum and matching or testing
the energy, the power
coming out of the solar cell
versus the power going in.
So a typical quantum
efficiency curve
might look something like this.
Let's walk through the
axes first and then
talk about the curve.
So the axes, we have wavelength
on the x-axis, on the abscissa.
Then on the ordinate, we
have quantum efficiency.
Wavelength is varying
from, let's say,
the ultraviolet to the
infrared and beyond.
Well, beyond the red into the
near infrared and probably
ending somewhere on
the mid-infrared.
And the quantum efficiency
extends from 0 to 1,
in other words from 0% to 100%.
And we have this box that's
represented by this maroon line
right here entitled
Ideal Quantum Efficiency.
And this would be if at the
band gap energy, all of a sudden
our quantum efficiency turned
on to 100% and cut across.
And this was the assumption
that we made in our homework,
that the solar cell device would
respond in this ideal manner.
In reality, at longer
wavelengths here,
what's going on?
Why would there be a decrease
of the quantum efficiency
at longer wavelengths?
What effect is happening there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the absorption
coefficient is dropping.
And this light is starting to
go straight through the device.
There's a growing
fraction of photons
that are not being absorbed
by the solar cell device.
In the very short wavelengths
right here, as I said before,
oftentimes there's
a dead layer right
near the surface of the device
that's impeding good electron
hole pair charge separation
and eventually a collection.
And right here in
the middle, there's
a slow but steady decrease
of the quantum efficiency
typically.
These are photons that are being
absorbed in the absorber layer.
If you think about your
solar cell in cross section,
here's your solar
cell in cross section,
these are photos being
absorbed in the absorber
layer generating electron hole
pairs which are then being
separated by the junction.
And as we go to longer
and longer wavelengths,
if you remember your optical
absorption coefficient begins
dropping, that means that
the penetration depth
of the light, the
average penetration
that the light is increasing.
And so the average distance
that the electron hole
pairs are being generated from
the junction is increasing.
So in other words, as we
go from short wavelengths
to longer wavelengths,
the distance
from which the
electron hole pairs
are being generated from
the junction is increasing.
That means that the electron
hole pairs generated
at these wavelengths
have further
to travel to reach the junction
than those electron hole
pairs generated at
these wavelengths
closer to the front surface.
And since there's a
finite probability
that the electron hole
pair will recombine
as it travels
through the material,
that's why you get this very
slow but steady decrease
of quantum efficiency over
the mid-wavelength range.
And on Tuesday we'll
talk more about that.
Internal quantum efficiency.
So for those who
say, well you know,
there's a certain
delta right here
between 1 and my
maximum response, here
my maximum quantum efficiency.
And I suspect that's
really due to the fact
that a certain
percentage of my photons
are being reflected
off the front surface.
I know how to
calculate reflectance.
We did that in lecture number
two or three, I believe.
So we know how to
calculate reflectance
off the front surface.
We can also measure reflectance
using a spectrophotometer.
And what we can do is normalize
the effect of reflectance out.
By dividing our external
quantum efficiency
by 1 minus R, what in
effect we're doing is
we're normalizing the
effective reflectance
out of our measurement.
So now we're only
considering those photons
they get into the device.
If you want, you can think
about the extreme cases there.
If reflectance is 0, that means
your EQE is equal to your IQE,
your internal
quantum efficiency is
equal to the external
quantum efficiency.
But if reflectance is, say,
50%, if 50% of your photons
are being reflected off the
front surface of your device,
now your IQE is
probably going to be
double your external
quantum efficiency.
And so now this is an
interesting parameter because,
for example, in our lab
scale devices when we're
testing them, oftentimes
we don't optimize
for optical properties.
Sometimes we do,
but many times where
we're focused on the material,
we're focused on the junction,
and we don't bother to put
the perfect entry reflective
coating on it.
It would take too
long to fabricate it.
And so IQE gives
us a good metric
of how the solar
cell is responding
if we were to go
through all the effort
to make the light capture
ideal for our device.
Okay?
And that's why we sometimes
use a report IQE in studies.
And typical peak values
are between 80% and 98%
for moderate efficiency devices.
So it would essentially--
the curve would look
very much like the EQE curve.
It would just be boosted up
by 1 over 1 minus R. Okay?
So any questions so far?
Make sure we're on
the same page here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So IQE is a function
of wavelength.
R, reflectivity, is also
going to be a strong function
of wavelength because
the real component
of the refractive
index is changing
as a function of wavelength.
Yeah, absolutely.
OK, so this gives you a sense.
Sorry for the poor choice of the
reflectivity colors right here.
This baby blue, which is
almost impossible to see,
but I've just traced it
out with my finger, that
denotes the reflectivity
as a function of wavelength
from some data that it
took as a graduate student.
So you have some typical quantum
efficiency curves right here.
And then the quantum efficiency
curves that are shown
are for a pretty
poor quality device.
And in this particular case,
I measured quantum efficiency
under short circuit conditions,
but with different illumination
intensities.
So going from 0 sun
illumination all the way up
to 1 sun illumination.
But the device was still in
short circuit conditions.
So what I was doing, in
effect, was flooding the device
with more and more
and more carriers,
and I got this boost here in
the middle wavelength range.
I still was limited
by my surface.
I was still limited by my band
gap and non-absorption effects
over here.
But in the middle, I was able
to get this boost in performance
simply because I was filling in
trap states inside of material.
This is an advanced
concept that we're
going to get to over
the next few lectures.
But it gives you a sense
of what a QE curve might
look like for device, what the
reflectivity might look like,
and these curves right here
were IQE, or internal quantum
efficiency.
OK, so take efficiency
with a grain of salt.
When you hear somebody
reporting an efficiency value,
ask-- think about what
efficiency is being measured.
Is it energy conversion
efficiency?4 is it quantum
efficiency?
Internal, external?
What wavelengths?
What is the nature of the
light being used, right?
Is a 1 sun illumination source
that has been well calibrated
to within 2% spectral
fidelity, spatial uniformity,
temporal stability?
Is it a really bona
fide good light source?
Or is this some
monochromatic light source
that somebody set up
because they knew, aha,
my solar cell really
responds well to, say,
500 nanometer lights, right?
So I'm going to test my-- I'm
going to report my values right
at that wavelength.
You have to take it
with a grain of salt.
Yeah, exactly.
And what is the
intensity of the light
that's being used as well.
That's very important as
we just saw right over here
because the bulk material is
going to respond differently.
There are certain trap
states for electrons
inside of the material.
And as you add more
and more light,
you're flooding those traps.
They become filled,
and the electrons
can move through the
material more easily.
That's why you get
this boost of response
as you increase the
illumination intensity
in this particular experiment.
So these are all questions
that you should ask yourselves
when you see
quantum efficiency--
internal quantum, external
quantum efficiency
values reported and/or energy
conversion efficiencies.
What is really happening?
What are they measuring?
This right here, a paper out of
Paul Alivisatos' lab from 2002
was, in my humble opinion,
an excellent example
of honest efficiency reporting.
First off, they picked
their highest values and put
their best foot forward, and
said look we have a quantum
efficiency over 54% , and a
monochromatic power conversion
efficiency of 6.9% under very
low intensity light at 515
nanometers, right.
So first off, they put their
best foot forward and said,
under optimal conditions
monochromatic light
that's what we get.
But also under air mass 1.5
global solar conditions,
under the standard
solar spectrum,
we obtained an energy conversion
efficiency, or a power
conversion efficiency of 1.7%.
So both values are put
there out on the table,
and they say look, here's a
characterization of our device.
So I really like this paper.
It was back in 2002
right at the beginning
of the new wave of new
materials in PV, so to speak,
this third wave of PV
in the United States.
And it was a beautiful example
of a really well-reported,
carefully described efficiency.
Any further thoughts
or comments before we
jump on to the next
topics of the day?
AUDIENCE: How do you have
a QE curve for 0 suns,
I noticed on your plot?
Or is that kind of
an extrapolated?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this is the
bias condition-- sorry the bias
lighting condition, not the
bias voltage as in battery,
but bias lighting as in
I shine a light source,
a polychromatic light
source at my material.
I believe in that
case it was a halogen
lamp with a series of filters
to simulate the solar spectrum.
And obviously you can't
measure a quantum efficiency
without having some
light involved.
And so the light that was being
generated by the monochrometer
was much lower in intensity
than these illumination
intensities here.
And so it was more of
a perturbation on top
of a steady-state background.
And we ran the measurement
exactly those conditions.
We had a steady-state
background light,
and then we chopped the
monochrometer light coming in ,
and used a lock in amplifier
to track that particular
frequency.
So we were able to detect
the small perturbation
due to the monochromatic
light coming in on top
of the steady background.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There's no
international centers
to report efficiency
or convention?
PROFESSOR: There are.
There are conventions,
international conventions,
to report energy
conversion efficiencies.
And I believe there might also
be for quantum efficiencies
as well.
Let me look into that.
Why don't we take note of that
and bring back the precise ASDM
standards next time.
And I believe also there are
other entities like IEC that
have their own systems for it.
There about four
laboratories worldwide
that are authorized to
give standard efficiency
measurements.
So they have very carefully
calibrated quantum efficiency
measurement devices,
very carefully calibrated
solar simulators.
And if you really think you
have a record efficiency cell,
you should get it checked at
one of those laboratories.
You shouldn't just report
what you have coming up
your lab-based system.
You may even want to go around
to a few different labs at MIT
first because one might
have a better calibrated
solar simulator than another.
What we're going
to do now is dive
into some of the
common factors that
cause solar cell IV curves to
deviate from normal ideal diode
model.
We're going to talk about
shunt and series resistance,
recombination
currents-- maybe we'll
get to current crowding,
some other effects.
Basically what we're
doing now in number two,
is we're beginning
to say, OK, now
that we understand
an ideal diode,
now that we have an
ideal picture of how
our solar cell works, let's
bring it down to real life
and talk about all the
things that can go wrong.
Because when you try to make
a solar cell in the lab,
these are the things
that are going
to start nipping at
your heels, so to speak.
So we'll start out with
an equivalent circuit
diagram of a solar cell device.
And this might be
new to some folks,
but it's all stuff
you've seen so far.
What we have over here is
the current generation source
of the solar cell operating
under forward bias conditions,
under illumination, generating
a voltage and a current.
We have a diode
here that prevents
the back flow of
current, and forces
the current to go out through
the external circuit loop.
And it forces it to drive
the external load, which
would be attached to that
little circle over there,
and that other little
circle over there.
So you can imagine
external circuit
attaching itself right there.
So the diode-- if the diode
quality is high, if it's good,
it will prevent the
backflow of current.
If the diode
quality is poor, you
will have so-called leakage
current, current leaking
into the diode back-- if
you want to think about
under forward bias conditions,
here's your solar cell forward
bias.
You have light, your
electrons coming in,
separated by the electric field.
Instead of powering
the external load
and coming back into the
device through the back,
leakage current would be
the electrons going back
up the barrier, going
back into the base
of the device, the
so-called diffusion current.
So this is that diode right
here representing the diffusion
current, or in that
particular case,
in the ideal, the
equivalent circuit diagram,
this is representing the
resistance to diffusion,
if you will.
So we have this voltage
and current being generated
by the solar cell, and
that would be described
by the ideal diode equation.
My apologies, there should be
actually a x of this minus 1
right there.
We should take note of
that and correct it.
I just happened to notice that.
OK, so the ideal diode
equation is right here.
And this is the current
density versus voltage.
So we have in linear
log scale or axes,
we have a straight line.
That would mean
on a linear scale,
we would have an
exponential curve.
So an exponential function,
exponential curve up here,
and a straight line
in linear log scale.
I'm trying to sensitize
you to the two
ways of looking at this,
both a linear scale and a log
scale of current in the y-axis
because both will tell us
something.
From the linear scale up
here in the upper right,
it will be very easy for
us to see the fill factor.
We can just glance at
that curve and see, oh,
it looks really box like.
It must have a
large fill factor.
From this curve down here we
can begin to see deviations
from ideality.
If anything causes this curve
to bend up or down, either
down here or up
here, we're going
to see it really quick
on the log scale.
And that's why looking at the IV
curve in both ways is helpful.
It's a method of diagnosing
the problem quickly.
So what we're going to do now is
to take our equivalent circuit
and begin adding a
few things to it that
represent realistic effects that
we might see in a real device.
So the first thing
that we might do
is say, well listen, a real
device has a finite series
resistance.
And that can come from
a variety of sources.
We'll talk about those
in a few minutes.
But we might add a series
resistance component
right up there.
So let's look back.
I'm going to flip back and
forth between the two slides
just so folks can really
see what the difference is.
This was the ideal case.
That's the with
series resistance,
again ideal with series up
there in the equivalent circuit.
Great.
So what have we done?
Well, we've added a series
resistance component
which is essentially
dropping the voltage output
of our solar cell.
And notice what else happened.
Now we have a
nonlinear equation.
Our current density
is a function
of our current density.
So this is becoming
more difficult to solve
analytically.
And what is happening to
our IV characteristics?
Well, let's look-- we'll go back
once again to our ideal diode
equation right here.
We have a very sharp
box-like IV curve
under the ideal conditions.
Now when we introduce the
series resistance component,
we begin smoothing
out that IV curve.
The fill factor has dropped.
Take a look.
Ideal conditions, sharp,
very large fill factor.
Now we've added the series
resistance component,
the fill factor
has begun dropping.
If we look at it
in log scale, it's
very easy to detect
that series resistance.
We can see it right here.
This used to be
our curve, right?
So again, this was the
ideal case, straight line.
Again, this is log of current
verses linear voltage.
So the x-axis of the two
plots here are the same.
I'm only changing the
y-axis from linear scale
up there to log scale down here.
And notice what happens.
If I add the series
resistance component,
now I begin dropping off.
So this is a telltale sign
when you take an IV curve
and you see that, then you have
some series resistance effect
inside of your external
circuit or your solar cell,
or some combination of the two.
Yes, Ashley?
ASHLEY: So from this curve it
looks the series resistance
really only starts
to have an effect
once you have a higher voltage.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
And that, you can begin to
see directly from the equation
right here as well.
Take the limit of low voltage
and the limit of high voltage.
Or another way to put it would
be the high current, really.
And the high current
to voltage ratio
only begins to take on up
at higher voltages because
of the exponential
function of that curve.
So that's a very, very
important and astute observation
that the series
resistance begins
to kill you at high forward
bias voltage conditions.
You hope that you design
your solar cell in such a way
that the series resistance
only really begins
to kick in above the
maximum power point voltage.
That's the goal.
AUDIENCE: This is not
voltage out, this is voltage
applied to the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This is the
voltage that is being
measured across the solar cell.
AUDIENCE: The output voltage.
PROFESSOR: The
output voltage, yeah.
Yes, you can think of this
as the biasing condition
of your solar cell device.
The two are almost equivalent.
The only difference is you
have that series resistance
in series there.
So you have to be
careful whether you're
talking about the voltage
here at the solar cell itself
across a junction,
or the voltage
coming out of your device that
is effected by that series
resistance as well.
So think of it is
doing that IV sweep
that we did in
class the other day.
So you're taking the IV
sweep of your device,
and you're seeing the impact
of the series resistance
in the output voltage you're
measuring of your solar cell
device, just like
we did in class.
So again, series resistance
will effect you at some point.
It is almost inevitable.
But you have to design
your solar cell such
that it effects you only
after the maximum power point.
Likewise, we're going to
introduce another resistance
term inside of our equivalent
circuit diagram, what
we call a shunt resistance.
Let me back up one step here.
This was just a
series resistance,
now I've added a shunt
resistance term here as well.
And whereas we wanted our series
resistance to be small, right?
The smaller our series
resistance, the less
this effect would be, the more
ideal this curve would be.
We want our shunt
resistance to be large,
because we want to prevent the
current from flowing inside
of the device back to the base.
Instead, we want
the current to flow
through the external circuit.
So we want the shunt
resistance to be large.
In other words, we don't
want our solar cell device
to full of shunts.
That's pretty obvious.
OK, so what does shunt
resistance do to you?
Well, if we compare
the IV curves
once again between
the solar cell just
with the series resistance, we
had a very low forward current
here under low forward
bias conditions.
If we have a very
poor shunt-- if we
have a plethora of shunt
pathways in our device,
we're going to get current
flowing through our device
even at low bias conditions.
That's because the
pn-junction is weak.
And even though we have a
very large field in there,
there are some regions where the
field is much smaller because
of the shunt pathway,
and current is going
to be flowing through there.
Diffusion current
will be flowing
through that shunt pathway.
So think of this as being
a very strong diode, right.
In the absence of
shunt resistance,
you have a very strong diode.
You have in your p-type
region and your n,
and that large
barrier is preventing
the diffusion of electrons
back into the device.
It's preventing
this from rising.
It's keeping it low.
And that can only happen
when the pn-junction barrier
is uniform throughout
your entire device.
If you have one
region if your device
that is poor that
has a shunt pathway,
maybe you have a piece of metal
that fired through the junction
and is making good ohmic
contact to both sides.
If you have a shunt
pathway, now the current
can flow even under
small bias conditions.
The diffusion current can
flow into your device.
And that, of course, drops
on the linear log scale
right up here, you
hardly detect it.
Notice, if we go back
and forth between
with and without
shunt resistance,
you can hardly
detect it right here
until you start getting to some
really leaky diodes, in which
case you begin to impact
your fill factor as well.
So shunt resistance is important
for a solar cell device
that it not be too, too high.
Because at some
point it does begin
impacting your fill factor.
Sorry, the shunt resistance
not be too, too low.
Yes, your shunt resistance
can't be too, too low
because at some
point it will begin
impacting your fill factor.
But more importantly,
shunt resistance
is usually indicative
of some localized
failure in your pn-junction.
It's usually not
homogeneously distributed
throughout the
entire pn-junction.
Maybe your first solar
cell device you ever make
might be effected by that.
But as you get
better and better,
you'll start making
higher quality junctions.
And usually the
shunt resistance is
indicative of one little spot.
And what happens at
that one little spot?
Well, current is flowing in
from the entire emitter region
into that one little shunt and
locally heating up your device.
And so that's why people worry
about shunts in industry,
is because if you have
current crowding into that one
little spot, it's heating
up, it's becoming a hotspot,
and it can even melt the
encapsulated materials
in your module.
Perhaps even create a fire
in extreme conditions.
And so when you test
the solar cell devices,
typically the IV tester will
measure the shunt resistance
in a solar cell by
looking at what's
happening under very small
bias conditions right here,
and comparing it
against the healthy cell
that it would expect.
And if it finds cells with
high shunt leakage current,
in other words, low
shunt resistance,
it will advise the
tester and sorter
to throw out those
cells, and so they'll
be put into the scrap pile.
And so the shunt resistance
manifests itself right here
in the ideal diode equation
in this term right there.
And so it's essentially
an add-on term
after your exponential,
looking something like this.
Essentially, at low
bias conditions,
you can extrapolate
this point right here,
determine the slope
of that point,
and find the shunt resistance.
And likewise, you'll notice
that the shunt resistance really
isn't impacting you up here.
The shunt resistance
really isn't impacting you
at higher forward
bias conditions.
That's mostly series resistance
in the illumination current
that's overwhelming
any shunt pathway.
Ashley, yeah?
ASHLEY: Do you know
for, I don't know,
a high-quality
manufacturer, what
percentage of produced cells
get tossed because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Very low.
The manufacturing yields of
a well-oiled manufacturing
line- I say oiled in
a figurative sense.
We're not typically-- yeah,
some of the parts, I suppose,
use oil.
In a well-functioning
manufacturing line,
the yields are upwards of
95% for cell fabrication.
So it's a very small percentage.
You typically see
this when you're
developing a new process.
And that's why I'm
informing all of you
about this is because we're all
developing new processes here,
right?
We're all working on
new solar cell devices.
And it's very important to be
aware of what's going wrong
in your device, not just that
you're getting a low efficiency
because this is the first
step to troubleshooting.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but why is it
bad that we have a
high current density?
[INAUDIBLE] current
density [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Why is it bad that
we have a high current density?
Why don't we go
back to simple case
right here where we have a
series instance, for instance,
right?
And so at, say, 0.5
volts forward bias,
we now have with the
series resistance, a higher
forward currend-- we'll
call a dark forward current
because we're measuring
this in the dark.
That's why we have 0 here.
And it's forward
current, meaning
it's like a diffusion current
going from the emitter
back into the base.
And so we have a higher
dark forward current here
in the dark with the
series resistance,
then if we didn't have the
series resistance, right?
So let me do that again.
We're up here at,
say, 1 times 10
to minus 2 milliamps
per square centimeter,
whereas before we were
down at around a quarter.
So why is that bad?
That's bad because when we
illuminate our solar cell
device, we are going to be
shifting that curve down,
and that's going to reduce
the total current output
at the maximum power point.
So anything that goes up here
when it's shifted or transposed
by a finite fixed
amount, it will
be closer to the 0 point of
current than it used to be.
That's why it's bad.
So anything that
increases that blue curve
and shifts it up in
the dark is going
to be bad for our solar cell.
In an ideal case, we want
our dark forward current
to be as small as possible.
We want our J0 to be
as tiny as possible
for a good solar cell device.
OK.
Good let me show you dynamically
what happens in a solar cell.
Oops, sorry about that.
Here we go.
So this is a PV CD-ROM
again in a beautiful example
of, in this particular case,
looks like series resistance.
So now we're at 1
ohm series resistance
for the entire device.
The ideal solar cell
is shown in red.
The IV curve for the ideal
solar cell is shown in red.
It would be a short
circuit current
of 35 milliamps per
square centimeter,
an open circuit voltage
of 624 millivolts,
and a fill factor of
83%, ideal solar cell.
The real solar cell now with 1
ohm series resistance, the fill
factor has dropped by
5% absolute down to 78%.
And now I'm going to
increase the fill factor.
What would you expect
to happen to that curve?
Flattens, right?
The fill factor drops.
So let me start increasing the
series resistance by manually
dragging this forward.
So now we're at around
2, 3, 4, 5, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So now we're at 10
ohms series resistance.
That means we have
a large resistance
inside of our solar cell
device at some point.
And our fill factor has
now dropped precipitously.
And if you remember
that efficiency
is proportional to fill,
factor that means we
have a problem with our device.
We're really dropping
the maximum power point.
the operating point
of our solar cell.
So if you were to do
an extreme condition,
you might have so
much series resistance
that your IV curve looks
like a straight line,
you have an ohmic resistor now.
The resistance component
is swamping out
any diode-like behavior
of your solar cell.
And that's why you have a line.
Likewise, you're dropping
the total current output
of your device,
right, because you
have a resistor in
series now that's
preventing the current flow.
OK, so that's, again,
an extreme case of what
can happen in a
shunt resistance.
Let me show you that as well.
So we have another beautiful
example shunt resistance here.
Now we start out with a
very high shunt resistance,
because in our equivalent
circuit diagram,
if we go back up here,
we have a large barrier
that prevents the current
from flowing back internally
inside of the device.
The current is
forced to go outside
through the external circuit.
But as we drop that red
shunt resistance component
right there, as we
decrease the magnitude
of the shunt resistance,
we will allow the current
to flow inside of the device.
Now we have internal
current loops,
and that means that we no longer
are forcing the current go
outside through the
external circuit.
And somewhere around
between 1,000 and 100 ohms
for our shunt
resistance, we really
begin to see that
drop in fill factor.
And as expected,
it's really begin
to impact us at the lower bias
voltages down here like we saw.
And at some point, we
drop the shunt resistance
so much that now the voltage
across our solar cell
is even suffering
because there's not
enough separation
of charge sustained
to make that voltage large
because the current is being
shunted back inside the device.
And again, we have what appears
to be very linear IV curve.
So you can see when you
measure your solar cell
and you test it, and you get
a linear IV curve instead
of that nice
exponential, you have
to do a little bit of
troubleshooting to figure out
what exactly is going on.
OK.
Good.
So key concepts so far.
We can add the effects
of parallel resistance.
What we typically refer
to a shunt resistance
is also called
parallel resistance
because it appears in
parallel with the diode inside
of the device, right.
So we can have a parallel or
shunt resistance and series
resistance in our devices.
And as an advanced
concept, I really
wanted to expose
you once, and we
can talk more about this in
office hours, to the notion
that in addition to just
having one saturation current,
you could envision difference
saturation currents coming
from different regions of
your solar cell device.
Let me walk you through that.
Under low bias conditions where
we have a large built in field,
and we have very
low bias conditions.
Before bias, obviously the
field is going to be decreasing,
the barrier height's going
to be decreasing as well.
So under low forward
bias conditions,
current is going to have a hard
time getting all the way up
into the base and recombining
inside of the base,
but some of the current could
recombine in the space charge
region of our device.
And that's why under low
forward bias conditions,
we might have what is called a
J02 current, or recombination
current in the
space-charge region.
And then there are high
forward bias conditions when
a lot of the carriers can
diffuse into the bulk,
and recombine
inside of the bulk,
we might be driven by different
recombination mechanisms,
bulk recombination mechaniss.
So that's sometimes
where you see
what is called a two-diode
model for a solar cell.
And the two-diode
model for a solar cell
would look very much
like this, except you'd
have two diodes one
right next to the other.
One that would effect you at
low bias conditions, another one
at large bias conditions.
You might see this
in your research.
It's really an advanced
concept more targeted
towards the graduate
students here.
Another thing you
might see pop up
is this ideality factor
showing up right down here.
The ideality factor
is a slope factor.
What that means is--
here if we go back
to this, if you change
your ideality factor,
you're changing the
slope in log scale.
It'd still be a straight line,
but if your ideality factor
increases, you would
get something like this.
If it decreases, the slope
would increase, right?
Because you have the
equation dependent on 1
over this parameter.
So the ideality
factor is important
as well because it indicates the
type of recombination mechanism
that's driving
the current inside
of that region of the device.
If anybody ever comes across
this in their research,
come talk to me.
I'd be happy point to
the right directions.
Or you could look up the
thesis of Keith McIntosh
from University of
New South Wales.
Excellent, excellent
thesis entitled,
"Humps, Lumps and Bumps:
Three Dimensional Effects
of the Current Voltage Curve
of Silicon Solar Cells."
Some of which might apply as
well to other material systems
as well.
And you can tell
where the lumps, humps
and bumps comes from.
It's really these lumps, humps
and bumps in the IV curve
he's talking about.
Excellent read,
very good thesis.
Highly recommended for those
who want to look into their IV
curves a little bit more.
It's kind of like looking
to the tea leaves, right?
Because there are
a number of things
that can be effecting
the IV curves.
We'll get to some of
those on Tuesday as well.
These are IV curves,
again in log scale
on the ordinate, linear
scale on the abscissa.
You notice there's
little commas here
because I took this data in
Germany so the decimal place is
written as a comma.
The IV curves vary in
shape and in style.
Let's look at this one
right here, this black one.
It starts up like this, and
then it goes flat for a while,
and then it becomes series
resistance dominated way up
at higher bias voltages.
Whereas this blue curve
right here, this one again,
you have the effect of shunt
resistance at lower buys
voltages.
Then you have one diode,
two diodes, and eventually
the series resistance
component coming in as well.
Or perhaps it's a
large shunt as well.
You don't really know until you
start fitting it, and modeling
it, and maybe measuring
the temperature dependence
and so forth.
So this gives you a
sense of the real life
diode IV curves that
you might get over
the course of your research,
and it gives you some tools
to use to begin parsing
through and figuring out
what's going wrong.
Let's talk about that.
Let's talk about
solving problems.
So fill factor.
What can impact the fill factor?
Well, we talked about the
need for a high fill factor
to produce a high power cell.
Very easy to understand.
The larger the fill factor, the
larger the maximum power point.
If you have a low fill factor,
your maximum power point
is going to drop.
Let me show you back and forth.
Good device, bad device, large
fill factor, low fill factor,
high maximum power point,
lower maximum power point.
OK, we talked about this.
OK, so causes of shunt
resistance, physical causes.
I alluded to this
earlier, but let's imagine
you have that weak spot
in your pn-junction.
This is meant to represent
pn-junction in two dimensions
now.
So, so far we've only taken
a cross section like this.
Now you have a
real device in 2D.
And what this is
meant to represent
to some local weakness
in the pn-junction.
And the current is now flowing
through that local weakness.
So that's a representation
in a 2D energy band diagram
E versus x versus y of a
shunt in realistic conditions.
So shunt series resistance,
on the other hand,
we talked about the effect
of high series resistance,
and we're going to
calculate the series
resistance for a solar cell.
In part, because
this is asked for you
on your homework assignment.
At least the graduate
students have
a problem pertaining to this.
So let's talk about the
different components
of series resistance.
We have a bulk current and
then a lateral current inside
of a typical solar cell device.
So sunlight comes in, shines,
generates electron hole pairs.
These electrons will diffuse
to the junction region,
and then they'll drift
across the junction,
wind up in this emitter
front surface region.
And eventually through lateral
diffusion reach the context
and be pulled out of the device.
So we have to consider these
two different components,
and pretty much the current all
the way from the back contact
to the front contact.
Any one of those things could
contribute to series resistance
in an additive sense.
So to put that pictorially,
we have bulk resistance,
emitter sheet resistance,
the contact resistance,
and in line losses
out of plane as we
travel along those front
contact metallization.
So bulk resistance.
This is another way to state
how to choose an absorber
thickness.
So we've talked about
choosing absorber thicknesses,
in other words, we've
talked about choosing
the thickness of our
solar cell device
based on how much light
we want to capture,
based on the optical
absorption coefficients.
Well guess what?
This is a
co-optimization problem.
We also have to worry
about the finite resistance
of the bulk
material, and we have
to spec the
thickness accordingly
so that we don't wind up with
too thick of a bulk material
and the series resistance
component will be too large.
So how to choose the
appropriate absorber thickness.
Let's talk about
that for a minute.
So you can measure a parameter
in the bulk called resistivity.
Resistivity will be given
as a function of q, which
is the charge, u, which is the
carrier mobility, which means
how easy is it for that carrier
to move around the lattice,
and n being the carry density.
So let's think that through.
Resistivity-- if our
carrier density goes up,
if we have more carriers
to transport the charge,
the resistive should go down.
That makes sense.
Check.
If the mobility goes up, meaning
it's easier for the carriers
to move around the lattice, then
the resistivity should go down.
Check.
OK, so that makes
good, intuitive sense.
Now the base resistance, in
other words, the resistance
that we should have as current
travels across the base,
across the absorber of our
material, which we also call
the base of our solar cell.
So as the total resistance, as
current goes across the base,
should be given as Rho, which
is a fundamental material
parameter combined with some
geometric parameters that
define the size
of our solar cell.
So l is going to be the length
of the conductive of path
which typically would be given
as the thickness of the device,
and A is the area
of current flow.
In other words, the dimension or
size of our solar cell device.
So to minimize
base resistance, we
want to have a very
thin solar cell device.
But wait a second.
If we make it very
thin, then what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You get
less absorption.
So you have to make
it a certain thickness
to get a good enough absorption.
Then we can compensate.
If we still need to drop
the base resistance,
we can increase the
area of the base.
And so far that
makes good sense.
There's nothing else
tugging for the area
to be the other
direction, right?
So we can make this solar
cell infinitely large, thick
as we want to be to
absorb all the light.
Great, OK.
Hold on to that
thought because we're
going to have another
constraining parameter that
pushes us in the opposite
way in a few slides.
All right, so the
emitter sheet resistance.
In other words, how to design
front contact metallization.
Emitter sheet resistance
refers to the resistance
of lateral current
that the carriers
will experience as
they move laterally
to reach the front contacts.
And again, we go back to this
fundamental material parameter
where we have resistivity
as a function of mobility,
and total dopant concentration.
Sorry, for some reason, I used
the big N here and a little n
on the previous slide.
But it's the same thing.
It's carrier density.
So again, our resistivity is
a function of carrier mobility
and carrier concentration, how
easy it is for the carriers
to move, and how many
of them are there.
For a thin layer,
a sheet resistance
can be described as the
integral of the resistivity
by the thickness of that layer.
Or to put it more simply,
if you have a uniform layer,
you simply multiply the
denominator here by thickness.
So this can be thought
in the following way.
If we have a thicker emitter,
we will be dropping the emitter
sheet resistance.
We will be dropping the
resistance component
that carriers experience as they
travel laterally through this.
And that makes sense
because, in effect,
as we increase the thickness
of this emitter region,
we're increasing the total cross
sectional area for the charges
to travel through.
So folks with me so far.
For the emitter sheet
resistance to be low,
we need the thickness
to be good enough,
the thickness to
be thick enough,
the carrier density
to be high enough,
and the mobility
to be large enough.
And oftentimes, the
resistivity of a material, you
might spend months trying
to optimize the resistivity
of your emitter region.
For those doing
thin film materials,
you might be working on
zinc oxide, aluminum doped,
or fluorine doped zinc
oxide, for instance.
And after months of tuning
the temperature and the oxygen
partial pressure during
the deposition process,
you're there and you
have what you have.
You have a certain carrier
density and a certain mobility.
And you can't do much more than
vary the geometric parameter
varying the thickness.
So what next?
If my thickness is
too big on my emitter,
if my thickness is
too big, I'm going
to be absorbing all of my
short wavelengths photons
in the front surface
of my device.
And maybe the current
collection probability
from that layer up here,
that has a very high carrier
density, is not going to be
as large-- in other words,
the current collection
efficiency won't be as large as
if I generated the carriers
here in the bulk because
of an effect called
Auger recombination,
which we'll get
to a few lectures.
So this front
surface region here
oftentimes is considered a
dead layer to a solar cell.
Its electrical properties
are very, very poor.
So if I make this
layer too thick,
sure I get rid of my emitter
sheet resistance term.
But at the same time I'm
killing my quantum efficiency
in the short wavelengths.
Because I'm not able to
absorb those short wavelength
photons and convert them
efficiently into electron hole
pairs.
So this is a story
about co-optimization
of different device parameters.
So let's keep this
thought for a minute.
And let's now try to
calculate the total power loss
due to the emitter sheet
resistance, because now we
have this weird unit
of ohms per square.
In reality, it's ohms.
But when we think about
emitter sheet resistance,
we're thinking about a
square of the material.
We have units of
ohms per square,
square being a
unit-less parameter.
So it has, let's
see, resistivity
had units of ohm centimeter,
we divided our resistivity
by our thickness of
that emitter region,
so our units became ohms.
And ohms per square here is
the units typically given
for emitter sheet resistance.
And now we have to convert this
into some meaningful parameter
for actual solar cell device.
So if we want the calculate
the fraction of power
lost due to this emitter
sheet resistance,
it's fairly straightforward.
We would have to think
about the current.
Since power is I
squared R, we have
to think about the current as
a function of the resistance,
right?
As a function of
the position here,
we're integrating over y, y
being the lateral dimension.
And we're integrating-- imagine
the separation between contacts
is S. So here's one
contact metal finger.
Here's the next
It's extracting charge
from the material.
And we have a certain distance,
S, right here between them.
So the maximum distance
that the current
would travel in
principle would be
S divided by 2, since
any current that
reaches the emitter over
here will be collected
by this contact grid, and
any electrons reaching
the emitter over here will
collected by that contact grid
finger.
OK, so now we have our current.
We can translate
that into here where
we have our b, b being
the vertical dimension,
y being the horizontal
dimension here.
And we would get this
equation coming out right
in the other side, which is
a function of the separation
of our contact metallization
fingers to the cubed,
to the third power.
So the power loss coming
from the solar cell device,
as we separate our
contact metallization
by small amount, this power loss
is going to go up very quickly.
That's a really deep
point to recognize here
because what this
means, in effect, is
that we can lose a lot of power
very quickly in our solar cell
device if we place our contact
fingers too far apart, due
to this emitter sheet
resistance effect,
due to the row sub s,
which is our emitter sheet
resistance right here.
OK, so then if we divide the
power loss by the maximum power
point, we essentially get
a normalized power loss.
And so if we want to,
say, limit this ratio
to a certain fraction,
say 4% of total power
is lost due to emitter
sheet resistance, now we
can define the
geometric parameter,
the distance between
the contact metal
that we need to do
an actual solar cell.
And if you run through
the calculations
with a typical set of parameters
for a silicon-based solar cell,
you'll find out that your
metallization fingers should
be separated on the
order of 4 millimeters.
And if you remember the
real solar cell devices
that you saw embedded
in that module,
the separation of the fingers
is just about 4 millimeters.
So this is where that finger
separation comes from.
In one case, you'd want to have
your fingers spaced really,
really close together to
minimize the emitter sheet
resistance.
But on the other hand, if you
place your fingers too close
together, your shading
the front surface
of your solar cell
with metal and light's
not going to get in to
generate electron hole pairs.
So that's the
optimization function
that's run right there.
Wow, so far I'm
counting three or four
of these different
parameters tugging
in different directions, right?
So you can begin to sense how
constrained the solar cell
device is in terms
of optimization
of all these parameters,
and how easy it
is to make a very low
efficiency device as a result,
how difficult it is to make
a high efficiency device.
So this is interesting.
So we have now the spacing,
the appropriate spacing
between fingers.
It's about 4 millimeters.
Which means if we're going to
be making a solar cell device,
say a thin film solar cell
device on a sheet of glass
with some transparent conducting
materials [INAUDIBLE],
and then we have our
source of device,
and we have their front surface
here, and we have, let's say,
something else on
top, we have to limit
how wide we make that device.
Otherwise, we could be
limited by our sheet
resistance in, say, the zinc
oxide layer of our device.
And this is interesting
now because previously
for the bulk resistance--
let's think back over
to our bulk resistance.
We wanted our area to be large
because we wanted to minimize
the bulk resistance.
Now we want the area to be small
so that we minimize our emitter
sheet resistance.
So you can see how
the current traveling
in two orthogonal directions
inside of our device
is really causing us
problems because we're
having to optimize
the same parameter
in different
directions for each.
It's tricky.
And I'm providing
you the tools here
to be able to sit
down and calculate out
what is the optimal
thickness, what
is the optimal thickness of
your emitter, of your base,
and what is the optimal lateral
dimensions of your solar cell
device to simultaneously
minimize your bulk resistance
and your emitter resistance
instead of a device.
And you can do it all now with
equations that I just gave you.
So it's pretty cool.
At least to first order.
AUDIENCE: How did you
define B, again, in that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
So B was a vertical dimension.
B is just given as
the distance here.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that's
going across like
if you look down on your model?
PROFESSOR:Yeah, you're looking
down on your solar cell.
So the pn-junction would be
planar to this view right here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
It's a bird's eye view
on the solar cell.
Any other questions?
OK, so contact resistance.
This is the next thing that
can kill a solar cell device.
Contact resistance-- we
want to minimize the contact
resistance, but the
first step to minimizing
is to measure, to know what your
contact resistance really is.
And one simple way to
measure contact resistance
is to take a cross section
of your solar cell device.
We have deposited, say,
four metal fingers on it,
and they're appropriately
spaced by, I don't know,
how many millimeters or so.
So you have a certain
contact resistance right here
between the metal and your
semiconductor material that's
denoted as R sub C. And then
there's a certain emitter
resistance that we just talked
about, R sub em right here.
And if you were to measure the
current passing through here
to here, or another
way to say it
is, the resistance for current
to pass from this point
to that point, you
might get, let's say,
this data point right here,
a total resistance value
of some value, and a distance
between the two probes of, say,
1 times d sub f we're
d sub f is the unit
distance between two adjacent
contact metallization fingers.
Now if we measure the
resistance between this point
and that point, we might
wind up with that data point
right here.
And if we measure the
resistance between this point
and that point-- we already
did that-- to this point
and that point, we might
wind up with that data point
right here, and so forth.
And what's happening?
Well, as a current
goes into the device,
it passes once through the
contact resistance, a certain n
times R sub em, n being the
number of metallization,
number pops, the number of
times we travel distance df.
And then it goes
out the other side,
again traveling through
the contact resistance.
So the slope of this line here
should be equal to the emitter
resistance.
And the offset, the
intercept at x equals 0 here,
the intercept should be 2
times the contact resistance.
Because in principle, that
would be the equivalent
of current going in and going
back out through this contact
resistance right here,
through the same one,
not traveling at all
through the emitter.
Obviously since that's
impossible to measure,
we have to determine that
through extrapolation
back to the y-axis.
So this so-called TLM method,
the transmission line method,
is a method that is used
to determine the contact
resistance of a
solar cell device.
You could either
perform it linearly
in this fashion right
here, or using a circular,
essentially an array
of concentric circles.
And the latter method is
typically preferred, especially
in thin film devices.
So this is how you measure
the contact resistance.
And then there are line losses.
So what can-- let me back
up one step-- what can
effect the contact resistance?
Typically, what effects
contact resistance
is the atomic interface
between your metal
and your semiconductor,
whether it's
an organic or an
inorganic semiconductor.
Bless you.
So the interface here is
what determines the contact
resistance, typically.
And of course,
the dopant density
within your semiconductor.
So components of the series
resistance in the line losses.
So line losses are
essentially the losses
in the contact metallization
lines out of plane.
What can cause a resistance in
the contact metallization line?
Well, intuitively we know that,
OK if the line is too small,
if the cross section
that line is too tiny,
then there's going to be a high
resistance to current travel
along that line.
And indeed that's the case.
Whoa, we have the
same exact equation
as we had for our
base resistance.
Now it's applied to the line,
because in principle it's
the same thing.
We have current traveling
through in one direction
along a constrained
cross sectional
area, a certain distance,
a certain length.
So we have now a resistivity
given by the metal
obviously, because now we're
talking about the metal itself,
not the semiconductor anymore.
Currents traveling
along the contact metal
so that the row becomes the
resistivity of the metal, the A
becomes a cross sectional
area of the contact finger,
and the l is the length
of the conductive path.
In other words, how
long does the current
have to travel along
that contact metal
before it reaches a
highway, a bus bar, one
those really thick strips of
metal on our social device,
in which case it's home free.
So the R, the row rather,
the metal resistivity,
resistivities of several
metals and non-metal materials
are given here.
That's typically why you see
silver contact metallization
used for solar cells.
It's because it has a very
low resistivity, which
means that the resistance
line losses will be small.
Now, what is the
problem with silver?
Does anybody know what
percentage of the world's
silver right now manufactured
each year is currently
being used for contact
metallization on solar cells?
Take a number.
Guess.
AUDIENCE: 30.
PROFESSOR: A little lower, but
in that order of magnitude.
So he said 30.
Somewhere upwards of 10%,
right, would be your guess?
So around 10%.
And of course PV is growing
at a cumulative annual growth
rate in the several 10s
of percents per year.
So silver utilization
is expected
to continue to increase.
So either we mine
more silver, or we
venture to another
contact metal material.
And that's why you see
folks looking into copper.
Nickel, which is similar
in electronic structure.
It's one element to the left of
copper on the periodic table,
and another metal alternatives.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
where does nickel
fall on the resistivity chart?
PROFESSOR: I have to give
you the exact number,
but if I were to venture a
guess, what you're noticing
over here are several
of the metals that fall
in the noble metal category.
These are far to the
right on the 3D series.
So if you picture the
periodic table again,
far in the 3D series you
have that d-shell orbital
completely filled.
And those outermost
electrons are then
screened by all the other
electrons in the system
and very loosely bound.
And so you can remove the
electrons fairly easily.
It's one of the reasons why
these elements in that class
have a higher conductivity,
a lower resistivity.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Copper doesn't seem
that much worse that silver.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So, yes, absolutely.
Copper doesn't seem so
much worse than silver.
So the contact
metallization pastes to date
have mostly been using silver.
Copper can oxidize
fairly easily.
So that's one
downside of copper.
Another problem with copper is
that it's a very fast diffuser.
It's very tiny.
And so the elastic
strain energy turn
as it tries to move through
a lattice is very small.
And as a result, it goes deep.
So when you fire your
contact metallization
when you create the
contact between your metal
and your semiconductor
underneath,
you run the risk of having
atoms diffuse into your device
and hurting the
efficiency, hurting
the ability of the solar
cell to collect carriers.
We'll are more about
that on Tuesday.
AUDIENCE: So it
becomes an impurity.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
it becomes an impurity.
In this case, unintentional.
So just remember
where the contact
is right here in the emitter.
OK, if it diffuses into
the emitter, it's OK.
The electrons at this point
are the majority carriers.
But if the metal diffuses
all the way into the bulk,
the electrons inside of the bulk
in here are minority carriers.
And they can be impacted by the
presence of that copper there.
All right, so I wanted to
get through at least one
more point to really set
us up well on Tuesday.
We want to be able to
calculate the Fermi
energy of a solar cell
as a function of dopan
concentration, illumination
condition and temperature.
So, so far we've really
talked about the Fermi energy,
the chemical potential inside
of a solar cell in hand wavy
terms.
We've talked about
general trends,
about how as we add more
electrons to our system,
say by doping, we shift
the Fermi energy up
because the average ensemble
energy of the electrons
is increasing.
But now we're going to be
calculating it and determining
how to calculate it.
So the question is
calculating Fermi energy.
So let's introduce
a new concept here.
So far we've talked about
and energy band diagram,
and drawn our valence
band, and drawn
our conduction
band, and of course
the band gap in between them.
We've drawn the valence band
and conduction bands as it
they were just continuum
density of states,
as if they were just
these blocks where
electrons could pile in.
In reality we have what's
called a density of states
in the valence band
and a density of states
in the conduction band.
If you want to think
about electrons as cars,
the density of states
could be considered
the number of parking
spaces there are
per floor in a parking garage.
As you increase the energy in
the case of a parking garage,
you increase your
potential energy
as you move your car
higher and higher.
In here, you would be increasing
the energy of the electrons
as you go higher and higher.
The increase in the
energy of holes as they
go lower and lower.
So we have a certain density of
states that is allowed inside
of our semiconductor.
And there's a very
small density of states
right at the band edge.
And that density
of states typically
increases as you go deeper
and deeper into the bands.
So now at absolute
zero, and the person
who probably knows more
about absolute zero
than anybody else
here in this room
is Kristy Simmons in the
back, who for her Ph.D.
Would work on very low
temperature experiments
down into the, what, 10s
of millikelvin range.
10s of millikelvin range--
it's very, very cold.
And then if you cool
things down a lot,
all the electrons
that were excited
will drop down, say, into
the valence band right here.
And what this is represented
is as a filled valence band
right there.
And as you begin
heating your system up,
some of the electrons will
have the thermal energy
to be excited
across the band gap.
So thermally excited
electrons here
represented in your
conduction band.
[WHISPERING]
So we have a certain number
of thermally excited electrons
here up into the
conduction band.
Oh, and these carriers we'll
call intrinsic carriers
because they're not
added by dopans.
We're not adding anything
to the semiconductor
to create dopans to
generate new carriers.
There are intrinsic
carries because they
came from the valence band,
went up to the conduction band.
So if we plot intrinsic
carrier concentration
as a function of
temperature, we see
a curve that looks like this.
And it follows this
expression right here,
which is called in an Arrhenius
equation in a generic form.
In this case it would be
intrinsic carrier concentration
as a function of temperature.
We'd have to substitute
this big N here
for intrinsic carrier
concentration,
some exponential
prefactor, and then
an activation energy,
the activation energy
being the energy needed to
create that free carrier.
The band gap energy
in this case.
The activation energy
divided by KbT,
the KbT being Boltzmann's
constant times
temperature in Kelvin.
Now, if we plot the same
functions that we just saw
in the previous slide a little
differently, we plot 1 over T--
see 1 over T right
-- and there--
and we plot the
log of this value.
So again, log of this value, we
can read the activation energy
off of the slope of this graph.
So that's why you typically
see Arrhenius plots plotted
in this way-- 1 over T
verses log of parameter--
because you can read the
activation energy straight off
of the graph.
It becomes very easy to see
the carrier concentration.
So again, at absolute
zero we have,
here the valence band
completely filled,
the conduction band completely
empty in our semiconductor.
And the probability of
occupancy of a state
inside of our semiconductor
is given by this box function
right here.
Now let's look at what
happens when we heat this up.
When we heat the sample
up, some of the electrons
that were in the higher energy
states are going to be excited.
So they used to be here
in lower energy states.
They are going to be excited
to higher energy states.
In the area of this
little shape right here
is equal to the area
of that little shape
right here because of
conservation of number
of electrons in our system.
If we multiply this by
the density of states,
this is the density of states in
the valence band minimized here
at the band edges,
and increasing
as we go deeper into the
bands for the valence band
and the conduction band.
So we take our probability
distribution function,
multiply it by the
density of states,
and we get the occupied density
of states in our semiconductor.
So now we see that there's some
number of missing electrons
that are now in the
conduction band.
They used to be in the valence
band at very low temperature.
But now as we increase
the temperature,
they've had the thermal
energy to excite
across given this probability
distribution function.
And these carriers are
now free to conduct
charge inside of our system.
So what do we do
with this framework,
with this understanding?
Well, we can look
at this function
here and ask ourselves, what
is the name of that function.
It's called the
Fermi-Dirac distribution,
and it's given by this
equation right here.
We'll notice in the
Fermi Dirac distribution,
we'll notice that this
equation approximates
to an exponential equation as
we move further and further away
from the Fermi energy, the
Fermi energy being defined
as this energy right here.
If we move further way down
here, or further way up here,
this starts looking an awful
lot like an exponential.
Meaning this right here
and this right here
start looking like
exponential functions.
OK, so let's do a quick
little Gedanken experiment is
a quick little thought
experiment, about what
happens when we heat
up a semiconductor.
And how would this impact, how
these free carriers right here
impact the noise, say, in a
camera, in a CCD-based camera.
A charge couple display
camera, which functions not
so different from a
solar cell device,
except that it's biased
a little differently
than an actual
solar cell device.
But it could be like
a pn-junction, p-i-n,
to be more precise.
So we have our little
camera right here,
and the camera's
typically placed inside
of a liquid nitrogen dewar if
we want very high performance.
These are not your
typical handheld cameras
that you would use for
shots in the street.
These are cameras that we use
in the laboratory for detecting
very faint signals inside of
our semiconductor systems.
And we typically cool
our cameras down.
Why?
Because we want to
minimize the density
of these intrinsic carriers.
Because any photon that
comes into our system,
we want to be able to
count it and to detect it.
And not have to detect
a very small signal
on top of a large background
noise of thermally
excited carriers.
In a solar cell device, the
intrinsic carrier concentration
is typically much, much less
than the dopant concentration.
So the intrinsic
carrier concentration
matters less for
our semiconductors
than it does for a photo
detector like this.
And that's why,
thankfully, we don't
have to cool our solar
cells with liquid nitrogen.
So in terms of have
intrinsic carries,
let's dwell there just
a little bit longer.
Transistors are made of
what semiconductor material
to have less electronic
noise to experience?
OK, so what semiconductor
material, germanium or silicon,
would experience less electronic
noise at room temperature?
And let me give you a hint.
Silicon has a band
gap of 1.1 eV.
Germanium has a
band gap of 0.67 eV.
Which of the two is going to
have greater electronic noise
at room temperature?
AUDIENCE: Germanium.
PROFESSOR: Germanium because
it has smaller band gap,
it's going to be easier
for the carriers-- we
go all the way back here-- it's
going to be easier for carriers
to hop across because
the band gap is smaller.
Another way to look at it
is on the Arrhenius plots,
you'll have a higher
carrier concentration
because your slope is smaller,
your activation energy
is smaller.
And as a result,
you'll have a higher--
if the band gap shrinks-- you'll
have a higher carrier density
here in the conduction band.
Let me show you that
in pictorial form.
So this is the silicon band gap.
This is the density of thermally
excited carriers for silicon.
Now we shrink the band gap.
Boom, we shrunk it.
Same probability distribution
function because we're
at the same temperature.
But now we have a
smaller band gap
so we have a higher
density of free carriers.
And true story, germanium
was one of the first crystals
to be purified during the
early days of semiconductors,
and silicon was
following germanium.
And silicon was
ultimately chosen
as the material of
choice for transistors
because the intrinsic carrier
concentration of germanium
was just too high for
most applications.
And so you can see the
intrinsic carrier concentration
at room temperature of
silicon is around 10 to the 10
whereas for germanium is
around 10 to the 13, three
orders of magnitude higher.
So, yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
would be most costly.
Absolutely.
And so you do see solar
cells like Concentrics
is one company that's
commercializing
gallium arsenide-based
solar cells.
But they have to concentrate the
sunlight into very small area
devices because the devices cost
so much to make per unit area.
So they take cheap plastic and
concentrate the sunlight down.
Yeah, and here's a
gallium arsenide.
The intrinsic
carrier concentration
is even less than
that of silicon
because the band gap is
1.4 eV instead of 1.1.
OK, so I think this is
a good place to stop.
I'm still not through
all the material.
Oh, we wanted to do one demo.
JOE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Do you want to do
it first thing next lecture?
JOE: That's fine.
We've got five more minutes.
Ah, we do have five more
minutes before 10 after.
OK, why don't we do
a quick demo then.
So what we're going to
do as Joe sets this up,
is I'll verbally describe
what's going to happen here.
We are going to
take this-- actually
let me go back to be Fermi-Dirac
distribution function.
This function right here,
as we increase temperature,
what happens to this?
This will look more and
more, shall we say, flat.
It won't actually
go flat, but it'll
become more and more
diagonal opposed
to box-like in function.
What that means is the
density of carriers,
the density of free carriers
will increase with temperature.
And because of the
Arrhenius dependence
here, we have an
exponential increase
of the number of free
carriers with temperature.
Because the function
right around this region
right here, which impacts
the electron concentration,
the conduction band,
this small portion
of the Fermi-Dirac
equation can be
approximated by an exponential.
If we have an
increasing temperature,
we should have a drastically
increasing carrier density.
And let's see if
that's indeed the case.
What we have is a piece
of intrinsic silicon just
with a battery
pack attached so we
have a field across that
piece of intrinsic silicon.
Whoops.
Here we go.
And we are going
to apply, again,
that field across the
intrinsic piece of silicon.
A certain current
will flow through it.
And then Joe has a
heat gun, so he's
going to heat up
the silicon and see
what happens as the Fermi-Dirac
equation here is effected
by temperature, we should
have an increasing density
of carriers in the
conduction band.
So let's see if that's
indeed the case.
Can somebody read off what the
current is currently measuring
there on our current meter?
AUDIENCE: It's about
9.8 microamps right now.
PROFESSOR: 9.8 microamps.
So this battery pack
of 3 volts right here
is it is forcing a
current of 9.8 microamps
across that little
slab of silicon that
is sitted right here.
And so Joe is going
to apply the heat gun,
and if none of the
contacts pop off,
let's see what will happen.
So we expect the
resistivity to go what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Down.
And the conductivity to go up.
All right, so let's see here.
So what's happening there folks?
It's going up?
So that's the --
JOE: So it went up to
around 50 microamps,
and can see it's dropping rather
dramatically now [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the current
that the material's
able to pass through
is increasing
as a result of the increasing
temperature, because you're
exciting more carriers
into the conduction band,
leaving more holes
in the valence band,
and these are free charge
carriers are able to conduct
charge through the material.
Cool, OK.
So with that, I will leave
you, and I will return Tuesday.
And Joe give a fantastic
lecture on device physics
as well since I
will be at a kickoff
meeting for a big NSF-related
center in Phoenix, Arizona.
But it will be great lecture.
You won't want to miss
it, and look forward
to seeing you on Tuesday.